Oh laser screwdriver who'd have Sonic
[Music]
alright folks
overdue doctor who reviewed time and
were up to the two part finale of Series
three so that means that we are talking
about sound of drums and last of the
Timelords but before we get into it this
episode is sponsored by the podcast
radio versus the Martians it is a
fantastic podcast I listen to it even
before they started sponsoring some of
my videos and because it's a podcast you
don't have to spend money on it give it
a listen you've you know you've got time
your life at work you've got to drive on
get what you're working out something
give a listen to Mike Gillis and Casey
Doran because they are awesome they're
funny they have smart guests they talk
about cool nerdy stuff kind of like what
I talk about but you know you don't have
to see their faces whereas you're kind
of stuck with mine
but they're awesome stuff radio versus
the Martians radio versus the Martians
calm and of course wherever you happen
to get your podcast I'm getting good at
this I didn't know what I was gonna
think of this one it's not like I've
never seen it before of course I have
but my perception of what it was and how
well it worked has really gotten muddled
Ivan tree watched this this story in a
long time my memory was that this master
didn't really do much for me and that
the resolution at the very end was it
was just it was just too cheesy
that was my memory which was not
completely off base that said having
every watched it I think I was I have
historically been a little bit harsher
on John Sims master than I think was
warrant at least in these performances
that's not to say that I think he's
great from top to bottom I don't I sell
a lot of problems with
particular interpretation of the master
but there is some good stuff with him
and I can I can actually even narrow
down exactly what with him works and
when he works and I will mention that in
a little bit so like I feel like I had
either forgotten or neglected to mention
you know what about his performance does
actually work for me but let's get to
before that so we've got the doctor
Martha and Captain Jack which is a
really fun dynamic the three of them
together and for the brief period before
they are caught they are working quite
well I was surprised how well Martha's
family actually worked considering that
they've never really left much of an
impression on me in any of their earlier
appearances something about that I think
all of the actors that they got the
mother especially was really good at
conveying a lot of thought and like
anger in her expressions in a way that
was believable because oftentimes you
get an actor's number good to express
anger without words and they just get
all but there was an intensity to to her
a lot of the time that that really sold
what was going on quite well so that
they were way better than I remember
them being Martha honestly has some
really strong moments in this as well I
love the doctor saying you know the you
can't try and help them you know I know
they're your friend but she just shuts
him up it's like don't talk to me I need
to do this and I love her putting her
foot down like that indium because the
strength she has behind it if she didn't
have the strength of her conviction on
that she would have come across like a
petulant child or someone who's panicky
but what she comes across as it's
someone who's nuckle endowment which I
really like and also feeds into how she
ultimately helps resolve the entire
situation by the conclusion of the story
jack is fun to have back he actually
doesn't get all that much to do except
to die and clip a little bit except he's
good at that so that works well enough I
actually I really wish that especially
considering that she technically came
back
I really wish we could have had more
time to spend with the Masters wife
because I feel like she had a
fascinating arc that we only catch tiny
glimpses of so like initially you know
we see her and we think she's she's a
prop and then you know she has the
conversation with that journalist and we
was oh no she's in on it and she even
seems to be enjoying it but then by the
end like there's no fun in this anymore
and she looks broken and of course she's
ultimately the one who shoots the master
which feels so telling and I feel like
there was a great amount of of story
conveyed without ever giving us the
details of why she was so broken within
a year but she conveyed that so well as
an actress that was terrific so let's
start talking about the master what I
don't like about John Simms master is
that he I'm not gonna say the master
can't be high energy but and I'm not
even gonna say the master can't have fun
with what he's doing but there's
something about the the sort of hopping
around he's almost like an evil Looney
Tunes character he's like he's like if
Daffy Duck started killing people I
practically expect him to star hop
around like that's the level that he's
playing it and I just don't enjoy it and
I enjoy it less now than when I saw it
the first time because since then I've
seen other masters I've seen Roger
Delgado be the master and I then we had
Missy and I've seen these and you know
Jeffrey beavers on Big Finish I've seen
interpretations of the master that I
like so much more and yeah I don't enjoy
seeing this ridiculous goofy the
that he's doing that said there are
points in which he is phenomenal and
that is basically any time he is
speaking with David Tennant any time the
master is talking to the doctor because
in those moments he quiets down and he
focuses and it's not about fun anymore
it is about this guy I've got a history
with this guy and when he focuses up
there's a great intensity and there is
so much history in the dynamic between
the two of them that does a lot right
there and I have to just like I I have
mixed feelings about the casting of
Johnson given the way that he played it
but if they were going to parallel David
Tennant's age and get a younger master
the chemistry and rivalry and sense of
history between the two of them whenever
they actually speak to each other is
phenomenal unfortunately that is the
minority of a screen time not like a
severe minority sound like oh that only
happens like twice no it's it's a fair
enough chunk but it's still the minority
of his screen time is actually spent
interacting directly with the doctor
which means for a good chunk of his
screen time I don't like him and that
just kind of is what it is
so what else have we got okay so the
takla feign um I like the concept of
them and I like the way and the pace at
which that was all laid out and revealed
so what I enjoy about that in particular
is that you know we get the paradox
machine and we don't get told executives
but like the name kind of says it all
he's gonna enable some kind of paradox
and then talk to a feint show up so we
don't know exactly what's going on but
it was really unsettling to see that
face in the ball and then to get the
implication that maybe it wasn't that
exact
little boy that talked to Martha but it
was someone who knew that memory and you
evoke that kid and I love that the
you'll when asked why are you doing this
why are you killing us because it's fun
and I think that works especially well
given that they evoked that child from
utopia because an answer like because
it's fun is a very childish answer and
the vocal performances of the toclafane
who speak also evokes that childishness
and that that can work quite well when
linked to the correct slightly creepy
kind of mentality which this has so they
work pretty well for me but it's not
just the master who isn't working for me
here I have a lot of issues with the
ending on multiple levels the first one
being how the resolution actually works
first of all I think they they did too
much to bring the doctor down load
because when he gets aged the first time
and you know he's just in a standard
old-age makeup I think that works and
actually it's a pretty good old age
makeup honestly but when they do it
again to the point that he shrinks out
and then he's in a frickin bird cage I'm
like no I can't take this seriously now
that's no longer sad and tragic that's
kind of ridiculous and so part of it is
starting from that point and then coming
back from that
and I'm not opposed to the concept of
basically the doctor is revived through
the power of prayer because it kind of
relies on I was gonna call it a trope
but I don't think it happens often
enough to be a trope but something in
general that I like which is stories
about story stories about the power of
stories and of storytelling and I enjoy
that and this does kind of feed into
that but for some reason it
doesn't quite click with me and maybe
it's because of by the time the entire
thing ends and this is necessarily
because of the doctor saved by prayer
thing but it all kind of all happens at
the same time so it happens in rapid
succession that the doctor gets revived
and then the paradox machine is blown up
and then a year of time is undone and I
think that more than anything else I
have a really big problem with because
if you're not going to play out the
consequences or have truly significant
fallout from something as massive as the
entire world world gets taken over the
population gets decimated and the world
is under the rule of this madman if
you're not gonna have that have a
notable impact on the world then why are
you doing it because the master could
still have had just as heavy an impact
on the doctor which is the impact that
works without having to enslave the
world for a year and then you undo it so
what was the point the masters important
damage is done to the doctor and that
did not require the entire world to be
taken over for a year again and then
just get rolled back anyways in order to
accomplish that damage so I don't have a
problem with the world being taken over
storyline I do have a problem with it
being undone to this degree because
again I'm just left thinking if you're
not willing to play out the consequences
then don't go that big and I will see if
I stick with this I think this might be
mmm I would say this is tied for worst
offender for a deus ex machina ending
and because
thing for me the truck truly egregious
deus ex machina ending isn't just one
where something basic get narrative Lee
gets pulled out of a writer's butt and
fixes the whole problem
the truly egregious deus ex machina
ending is the one that puts everything
back the way it was so that the entire
problem might as well not have even
happened because in the end there's no
consequence to it and that's what
happens here and that drags the entire
thing down a lot for me it picks up a
little bit with the death of the master
because I like his his spite ever
refusing to regenerate I still think
they dragged it out a little bit not his
death specifically but like after the
Matt after the takla Feiner sent back
there's this whole thing with the master
like he's gonna launch the missiles but
the doctor tells him no you're not and
then he doesn't I don't know what even
the point of that stuff that bit of it
was and like they could have just gone
from you know the toclafane being dealt
with and then the master gets shot like
that would have been fine there's that
weird interlude that doesn't need to be
there
I just feel overall that the that thing
has a handful of flabby elements that
your mileage may vary as far as how much
they bother you they do bother me quite
a bit but to be fair I do think in the
past looking back at this episode I
think those things that bother me were
lingering in my head and diminishing the
stuff that's good and there is quite a
bit that's good
also coming back to Martha leaving I do
like Martha making the choice to leave
on her own and I like that the doctor
doesn't really try and stop her you know
he offers to get going he just kind of
looks at her face and like okay he gets
it I don't love that she has to make the
comparison to her what was it her
flatmate and a boyfriend like I didn't I
didn't I don't think it was necessary to
make that parallel explicit I don't
think it serves
anything the moment was great before
that it's just added in but I do still
like that Martha chooses to leave I
think the decision was a very mature one
and I think the point of what she did it
was like yeah that's that's a good
that's a good point to do it so that is
yeah I'll wrap it up on that sound of
drums last of the Timelords
better than I remember it although the
problems were absolutely still there
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do cuz there's buttons and
links things that take you to things
like my patreon my book my Twitter merch
all sorts of stuff click on them and see
where they take you or don't that is
okay because at the end of the day
you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]